nous sommes le 19 avril et nous recevons
un expert en stratégie en logistique
internationale car c'est la journée
mondiale de la supply chain bonjour yann
alix un bon jour la soupe la chaîne
c'est la chaîne d'approvisionnement bon
france on va définir ce que c'est avant
d'expliquer à nos auditeurs pourquoi ils
ont intérêt à rester à l'écouté dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement
ça concerne tout le monde dans tous les
secteurs effectivement c'est la chaîne
logistique je préférerais même pas les
deux chaînes logistiques que deux
chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est la connexion avec des services des
compétences et des responsabilités entre
un producteur un distributeur un
transporteur et finalement vous et moi
les consommateurs donc ça concerne par
exemple tout ce qui est production de
matières premières qui doit arriver quel
endroit quel que soit cet endroit dans
le monde
effectivement matières premières mais
aussi produits manufacturés biens de
consommation courante etc
les vêtements que nous portons qui
viennent d'inde de chine d'haïti les
aliments que nous mangeons les agrumes
de république dominicaine le mouton de
nouvelle zélande le café du brésil et
d'ethiopie tout ça ne peut être possible
que si vous avez une excellente chaîne
logistique en amont et en aval
est ce que cette accélérer ce phénomène
de supply chain chaîne
d'approvisionnement à cause de cette
globalisation cette mondialisation qu'on
évoque depuis j'ai quand même pas mal
d'années je dirais même que la
globalisation c'est réaliser parce que
la chaîne de transport et la chaîne
logistique parfaitement efficiente pour
connecter tous les endroits du monde à
moindre frais parce que le transport
maritime notamment reste un des moyens
de transport les plus efficaces et les
moins chers du monde
alors pourquoi faut-il en parler
aujourd'hui puisque finalement cette
chaîne d'alimentation
d'approvisionnement et s'est creusé au
fur et à mesure c'est une évidence vous
avez parler d'accélération est
aujourd'hui effectivement la
constitution de géants société privée
qui organise finalement la structuration
des flux logistiques à la chaîne
internationale et donc vous avez des
grandes massification qui s'opère entre
les grands blocs commerciaux et
l'important pour l'espace caraïbe c'est
de comprendre sa place dans cette
globalisation des échanges qui quand
même maîtrisé aujourd'hui par quelques
acteurs massifier européens notamment
alors parlons déjà des chemins des
nouvelles routes ce qui se crée par
exemple on parle
la création de cette troisième écluses
du pana bas d'autres pays comme le
nicaragua le honduras le guatemala
voudrait également créé leur canal parce
que tout simplement on constate que
c'est une masse d'argent aussi que ça
peut créer ce que ça peut susciter
effectivement parce que c'est la
facilitation dans de connecter deux
énormes blocs commerciaux que sont la
chine et l'asie du sud est en règle
générale et l'amérique du nord en
particulier et donc effectivement ça
représente une opportunité de raccourcir
le temps de transit entre des espaces de
production et des espaces de
consommation
d'où la nécessité de construire des ce
que j'appellerais des raccourcis
logistique que sont les ismes comme le
com panama on y aura encore une nouvelle
route qui fait déjà parler pas mal c'est
le pôle nord puisqu'il ya de la fonte
des glaces taos il faut regarder ça
alors je serais plus nuancée par exemple
parce qu'alors d'aujourd'hui au niveau
de la route des pôles la plus sérieuse
c'est celle qui va relier le nord de la
chine au nord de l'europe et à la
scandinavie via l'espace maritime russe
alors que du côté canadien les problèmes
éthiques sont beaucoup plus complexes
donc le le fameux raccourcis des pôles
deviendra une réalité certainement plus
importantes du côté russe que 2 que du
côté de l'amérique en règle générale et
donc vis-à-vis de la caraïbe c'est moins
alors justement revenons vers la vie la
zone caraïbes le canal de panama va
battre tous les records en 2010 8 400
millions de tonnes vont transiter par là
de l'autre côté de la planète du côté de
du pacifique le port de papeete en
polynésie aménage ses équipements pour
en profiter face à ce nouvel ordre
mondial du transport de marchandises
la caraïbe doit forcément se mettre au
goût du jour est ce que nous avons tous
les arguments qu'il faut pour vous avez
tout à fait raison le prendre la
problématique de l'élargissement du
canal de panama c'est qu'il faut en
comprendre la nature des flux qui
transitent par le canal
si je vous dis que deux tiers des flux
qui transitent par le canal vont
viennent des états unis
quel est le rôle de la careï dans cet
espace de transition que représente
l'espace caribéen entre l'amérique du
nord enfin tout du moins les états unis
et le canal de panama
c'est pour ça qu'on a beaucoup de
stratégie de hub d'éclatement donc de
regroupement des flux pour pouvoir mieux
les disperser et c'est là grandes luttes
d'aujourd'hui c'est qui sera le hub de
demain avec cette deuxième phase
d'élargissement du canal de panama
caraïbes doit tout ça qu'elle épingle
peut-elle tirer de ce jeu là aujourd'hui
je voudrais être très optimiste c'est
que l'espace caribéen
c'était un espace mosaïque avec
énormément de territoire des faibles
volumétrie donc des surcoûts logistique
tout ça est mécanique tout ça est normal
avec l'influent l'afflux de nouvelles
matières premières l'afflux de nouveaux
trafics l'afflux de nouvelles
opportunités de croisière avec le canal
il ya nécessairement des opportunités à
prendre pour certains territoires de la
caraïbe ça va être une lutte alors que
finalement je pense qu'il faudrait même
plus penser la planification aller à
l'échelle territoriale de l'espace
caribéen
aujourd'hui on atteindrait suivante un
rêveur monsieur yann alix ces poussières
deal qui n'arrivent pas à s'entendre par
exemple pour organiser une compagnie
aérienne très efficace pourrait se
mettre d'accord sur leflux maritime des
marchandises est hélas vous avez raison
et c'est le marché qui tranchera quand c
est ma cgm fait un investissement de
plusieurs centaines de millions à
kingston jamaïque
ccm à cgm qui décide de la pertinence de
l'attractivité de la compétitivité du
port de kingston et quand il fait un
investissement comme celui-là kingston
il ne fait pas à fort de france où il ne
le fait pas dans une autre il alors
comment fort de france comme en pointe à
pitre pourrait profiter de cet afflux de
de fret maritime
comment faire pour que les martiniquais
ne restent pas là tout simplement avec
une paire de jumelles depuis la côte et
regarder les bateaux passent et je sais
que c'est un sujet sensible mais il
suffit de regarder ce qui se passe à
l'échelle de la planète aujourd'hui les
autorités portuaires sont exemple ne
font plus d'argent
elles sont sous la pression des marchés
des opérateurs privés est donc là
aujourd'hui une des stratégies opéré par
les opérateurs maritimes c'est de se
regrouper
vous avez des ports et ses rêves
réellement une opportunité il faut bien
comprendre que des autorités portuaires
se regroupent et pas dans des
associations mais bien dans des schémas
de fusion pour être plus fort tout
simplement pour être plus solide face
aux pressions
du marché et notamment ce la pression
des opérateurs privés c'est très
intéressant d'entendre cela parce qu'il
n'ya pas si longtemps que cela on
entendait quand même cette rivalité
entre les ports de fort-de-france et de
pointe-à-pitre
concernant ben justement cette troisième
opus de panama donc cette querelle était
vaine stupide ridicule
j'aimerais peut-être pas jusque là mais
par contre effectivement je pense que
c'est pas nécessairement la bonne
stratégie de planification à l'échelle
d'une région
quand on considère la petitesse des
volumétries vous êtes impact est
nécessairement vous payer plus cher le
kilo de riz vous payer plus cher un
produit manufacturé parce que vous avez
des volumes qui sont très faibles donc
être ensemble pour être plus fort je
pense que c'est véritablement pas une
illusion parce que de toute façon c'est
ça ou alors vous avez de plus en plus
marginalisée par rapport à des
stratégies qui vont vous échapper
revenons à cette question de stratégie
et de et de logistique
vous êtes en train de nous dire que si
nous avions nathalie jean ceux de nous
rassembler nous pourrions peut-être
recevoir de la marchandise et payer
moins cher c'est je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce que vous venez
d'expliquer alors que devons-nous par
exemple ici en martinique développer ce
sont des infrastructures pour accueillir
davantage de bateaux ce sont des
services c'est très pro c'est très
important d'en parler parce qu'il ya des
jeunes qui les écoutent ya des parents
de jeunes qui vont rentrer dans des
filières de formation alors que faire là
aujourd'hui une étape essentielle qui
n'est peut-être pas encore complétée ici
c'est véritablement de travailler en
communauté
la chaîne logistique c'est une ans est
un ensemble de compétences qui a eu
l'habitude de travailler en silo pour se
protéger et aujourd'hui il faut faire
éclater ses silos et travailler
véritablement de manière communautaire
quels sont les métiers dans ces chaînes
de logistique à vous avez j'étais hier
soir avec des transitaires des
commissionnaires en douane donc des gens
qui ont la compétence de faire bouger
influent dans une chaîne quand vous êtes
un producteur vous voulez envoyer votre
produit à l'autre bout de la planète
ça demande un transporteur sa demande à
stocker
on fait du stockage sa demande de
groupes et de dégrouper des flux parce
que parfois vous avez pas la capacité de
mettre tout dans un seul conteneur ou
vous êtes trop petit pour prendre votre
conteneur tout seul donc c'est une somme
de compétences comme ça qui sont très
importantes mais il faut pas oublier par
exemple que avec la révolution digitale
et l'utilisation de smartphones par
exemple on va avoir une digitalisation
du process logistiques et donc on va
voir des nouveaux métiers notamment du
côté juridique le droit vis-à-vis de la
signature électronique sur un contrat
par exemple
donc ce ne sont pas uniquement les gros
bras pour pouvoir décharger les
marchandises sur les bateaux absolument
pas absolument pas c'est vraiment une
vision un petit peu passéistes excusez
moi de le dire comme ça
la logistique aujourd'hui c'est une
somme de métier de compétences
considérables ont fait du marketing on
fait de la communication ont fait des
langues
les langues sont fondamentales aussi
aujourd'hui moi j'ai enseigné en chine
et les chinois apprenait l'anglais pour
faire de la logistique pas pour
apprendre l'anglais
est ce que cette cette logistique il ya
suffisamment d'informations d'ailleurs
ça représente quel poids par exemple sur
dans le produit intérieur brut des pays
comme la france
ah ça c'est une excellente question
parce qu on a du mal à calculer c'est
une question de méthode
c'est une question de méthodologie camp
et quand commencer quand finit
finalement la valeur logistique sur un
produit ou sur une activité et c'est
assez complexe
l'association française de la logistique
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée a
estimé qu'ils allaient avoir un demi
million d'emplois dans la logistique
d'ici les cinq prochaines années il faut
que la partie des clubs profitent
on va reparler de tout cela aujourd'hui
à l'ancienne aérogare du lamentin
l'occasion de cette journée de la chaîne
de la souplesse chaîne qui se tient donc
avec le cluster carrie merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin yann alix bonheur
c'est beaucoup
[Musique]